the plastic waste situation
in colombia is actually not very good
only in bogotá
we are sending
approximately 600 tons of
plastic waste a day to the landfill
and we are recycling only feel
so from thinking about
the plastic problem we could also
attack another problem
The housing deficit is important
[Music]
My name is Oscar Méndez and I am the
Strategic Business Manager for
Plastic Concepts. My name is Isabel
Cristina Gámez and I am empty of the
Plastic Concepts company. It is the union of two
passions. One of the issues is  for the
environment and the other is for creating
products that reach and benefit
vulnerable communities
and from there came the idea of creating homes
from recycled plastic [Musi
] the p
astic that we obtain comes from
arious sources we do it throu
h  the associations of recyclers that
work in alliance with us
once the waste  they are collected, they
send it to our plant so that
we can make the transformation, we can
use shampoo bottles,
food packaging, plastic chair bins,
the characteristics of plastic itself
are that it is a material that does not degrade
easily over time, so when
we  we do the whole process and
we add our additives and we unite and
we heat the material
so that its physical characteristics are
maintained and last and it is durable for more
than 500,600 years
today we are around 4,000
square meters built and we have
transformed a little more than  500
tons of waste
in terms of the number of homes
built, we are above
25-30 homes.
We have always sought to
benefit people who do not have a
decent roof over their heads. Sometimes what reaches
this type of population is
low-quality materials.  quality then what we
want is to arrive with a material with
technical characteristics that  e are worthy
of living so that low-
income people can improve their quality of
life generating awareness of
sustainability from the communities is
very important because the planet
needs it and knowing that with these
materials we can create solutions to
change or to generate new products
or new  ideas or new changes
[Music]